I'm excited to talk with you all today
about stuff that I enjoy thinking about
I'm excited to hear stuff that you enjoy
thinking about as well um but uh okay
let's go so my research goal at a very
high level is to sense input performed
with physical devices that are deeply
custom or you could think like well
suited to the user their task and the
context they're in and as Michael noted
I use digital fabrication for this a lot
because I find it's a very Nifty tool so
what is digital fabrication do any of
you know have any of ever done digital
fabrication what is it oh uh
somehow uh using digital medals to
transform physical matter exactly yeah
you take digital stuff and you make it
into physical stuff so this as computer
scientists is very exciting for us
because we're really good at making
digital stuff
um I also as I mentioned in my research
statement think a lot about sensing so
what's
sensing no
way uh
oh okay no worries fail
347 um so when I think about sensing I
think about I'm doing something in the
physical world so like I'm pushing my
mouse and I want to move the pointer on
the screen right but there's a lot of
different ways that I can sense this
actual interaction so today's mice
usually use a laser on the bottom so we
look at the flow of uh of data as I
slide it across the table older mice
used a physical ball rolling around that
we measure the rotation of um but we can
get a little more exotic so if I know
what table I'm moving my mouse on maybe
I can set up some microphones and listen
to where on the table I'm moving it it's
also my body that's actually moving so
if I use a connect I can see how my arm
is transforming and turn that into Mouse
motion um or I can even listen actually
to my muscles listen to the electrical
signals going through my muscles to see
okay where am I pushing the mouse how
hard am I pushing it so sensing uh
straddles the line between the physical
world and the digital world but it's
extremely flexible there's a lot of
different ways to think about
sensing so sensing goes between the
physical world and the digital world and
digital fabrication goes between the
digital world and the physical world so
this is uh maybe a thing that you
remember from an early CS uh HCI class
but I think of this as like the Gul of
fabrication and the Gulf of sensing did
I just hear a Gran it's
[Laughter]
good um so this is how I like to think
about my research I'm thinking about
instead of execution and evaluation I'm
thinking about the gulf fabrication and
Gulf of sensing and the stuff I like to
think about in these contexts are called
tangible input devices um so all of
these objects are what I would call
tangible input devices and they're sort
of physical ways that we give form to
digital information so instead instead
of just pulling out my phone and using
the flat glass touch screen for every
application I interact with when I'm
mixing music I might use a turntable if
I'm playing a driving game you know I'll
use a carwheel so there's a lot of great
reasons to use tangible input devices um
virtuosity speed benefits etc etc
Michael probably made you read some
papers about it I'm not going to go into
that so going to this deeply Custom
Concept um You probably don't want to
use the same even though tangible input
device are great you probably don't want
to use the same input device to play
games as you use to write your term
papers um and you probably don't want to
use the same device as the person
sitting next to you either even if
you're both writing term papers um and
it may also be that your desired input
device changes when you're sitting in
class and trying to be secret about
texting versus when you're laying in
your bed and you're thinking about what
Tik Tok should I fall asleep to right so
the the sort of user task and context
all really uniquely determine the kind
of device that you want to use um so
making devices for all of these
situations is really complicated and uh
I've spent a long time thinking about it
but uh today we'll talk about like a few
different things that we can think about
for this so the uh the things that I
would like to cover are how can we make
functional devices quickly um this is
sort of like the bread and butter of the
stuff that I do uh we'll talk about how
we design stuff to make it easy to sense
um we'll also talk about designing
useful devices automatically
specifically for ergonomic reasons um
and then we'll talk about completely
ignoring design and uh thinking about
other weird ways that we can
conceptualize input
devices so talking about devices for
sensing uh I love 3D printing laser
cutting and otherwise making stuff that
we can sense so uh let's talk about a
little bit of a strange sensing method
well honestly they're both strange but
we'll start with uh this one so I'm
going to talk about how to sense stuff
using air as opposed to
Electronics this is a sequence that I've
used in probably every talk that I've
ever given since 2012 um but the
question is how do you make a tangible
input device uh you create the shape of
the device usually using digital
fabrication you print out a shell and
then you come up with a bunch of
electronics that you stuff inside you do
a bunch of soldering you program your
microcontroller and then you can sense
what people do with it but as I'm sure
you can guess this is extremely tedious
if you need to change the design it's
super painful so thinking about that um
we we came up with this idea of air
logic uh we presented this at Wiis L
year so air logic is a system that uses
flu Erics which I will tell you what
that is in a second um but we embed
input output and computation in 3D
printed objects uh objects are produced
as a single structure with minimal to
know
assembly so what the heck is fluex fluex
was developed between the 19 1960s and
the 1980s when people were in the midst
of the Cold War and afraid of radiation
frying all their Electronics so they
were like well what's kind of computer
that won't be bothered by radiation so
they came up with this idea of fluid
Computing so you basically shoot air
through these very specially shaped
channels and you can do logic you can do
storage you can do all kinds of
different stuff with
these and why does that make it a good
uh technique for tangible input devices
um it allows us to fully produce the
shape okay so we have the the outer
shape of the device and the function so
the input output and computation on a
single machine in a single process we
can actually do sensing so I'll talk
about sensing um we can do processing in
terms of logic uh and we can do output
all together and objects that use air
logic don't have to be reset in between
uses so there's been a lot of digital
fabrication work on meta materials that
requires you know you can push a thing
and it will transfer your signals
through the meta material but then if
you want to run the computation again
you sort of have to reset it so we don't
have to do that but how does it work we
rely on printing custom internal
geometry uh at the side there that's
connected with tubes um so we call these
transits because unlike electronic
circuits the air only goes one way
through it doesn't come all the way back
around so this example bunny has a
Transit that can sense two input
locations uh on its head and when either
one is interacted with it Wiggles its
tail but how does it really work right
so the Trent that I described before
I've unfolded here um and it has two
input widgets one or logic widget and
one wiggler so when we put air through
these widgets it basically comes out the
top um but then if I cover one of them
with my finger suddenly the air is
staying inside and it's heading into
this next part which is the logic gate
and basically the logic gate treats a
stream of err as a one and no stream of
err as a zero uh so similar to the or
Gates we all know because this now has a
one coming in one side and a zero coming
in the other side we want to send a one
through and uh it comes out by wiggling
this widget at the
end so of course we can do more with air
logic than just make a bunny um so we
developed a whole bunch of input output
and logic widgets that we can use the
input widgets all sort of rely on this
idea of keeping the air inside so the
air Escapes in all these cases on the
left where it's uh open and then it
stays inside when it's closed so we can
close it with a finger or we can close
it with a button rock or switches we
also developed some sliders and dials
that let you choose between multiple uh
air inputs um if you line them all up in
3D good question just make sure I'm
understanding does the device have to be
sitting on top of a fan or something
like that we use an air compressor we we
mostly use an air compressor we actually
did do one with lungs which I'll show as
well but uh but yes you do need a source
of air to make this
work logic widgets um they're doing
binary logic based on their inputs so
like I said before presence of air is a
one and absence of air is a zero and the
way that all of these work is the
principle of jet um deflection or jet
interaction um which tells us that a jet
can actually a jet of air can be
redirected by another jet of air if we
hit it in the right way so we can use
this for calculation here I have um a
schematic widget and if I blow air
through this side it continues out that
side same way if I blow air through this
side it continues straight out the other
way but if I blow air through both of
them I cancel out their angular momentum
so that the air comes out instead across
the
middle so we use this principle in all
of our
gates and I'm sure that some of you
realize that the gate I just described
is an and gate so when both of the uh
inputs are present we get an output on
the channel that comes out to the right
so that's the channel That We're
sampling to see if we have both A and B
as
true we use a similar shape for exor uh
so except we sample a different channel
so in this case When A and B are both
true we have the air coming out this
thing which pops into 3D it's a little
hard to understand from this
image um for notot we basically can use
a single Power Stream and when we have
our a input present it redirects away
from the uh the sample so we sample on
this one on the top right to see if if
we have not
a and then the ore I talked about with
the bunny basically it works as a merge
to connect the the A and B's both to the
same
out so for the final part in the chain
we have all these different output
widgets that we developed that give uh
visual audio um or haptic feedback so
the the top one pops a pin up so you can
see when when we have air present the
next one makes a whistle we can wiggle
the tail of the bunny like I showed or
or this one spins a fan fast enough that
you can feel the device vibrating in
your
hand to play around with the widgets we
made a uh Fusion 360 plugin that lets
you you know drop them in um cut them
out of your model and include them and
then finally of course you print them
out um with all the widgets
integrated we also did a bunch of
experiments to figure out how well they
work and uh it turns out that it's
really complicated um I'm not going to
go into it too much 3D printers are
very well they're not perfect yet that's
that's what I'll say um but we made a
lot of cool applications still even
given the uh the limitations of today's
3D printing so this uh this object
basically can tell when you've spelled
Wiis correctly and it pops up a PIN to
tell you that that's
right um this device uh lets you select
between different pitches um this is the
long powered one that I was talking
about so this one doesn't use an air
compressor um oh I apparently didn't get
my sound going through
this but anyway uh you can select
pitches and play them on this
whistle there's obviously a lot of ways
in which this is not as good as
Electronics right so we have pretty
limited sensing we also even though in
the 60s to 80s they did develop storage
methods that use air we could got could
not get those to work with our 3D
printed stuff um so there's there's many
ways in which this is like not quite as
handy as just using um microcontrollers
but there's also a lot of ways that it's
way cooler so these things don't care
when they get wet they don't care when
they get irradiated which is what they
were originally designed for they also
uh they're in some sense they can be
more sustainable because uh you don't
have to pull out any electronic parts or
metal when you need to recycle them you
just throw the whole thing in the
plastic bin right so it's 100% plastic
you push air through there's also uh
places where you might have access to
air or fluid flow um that you don't have
access to electricity like when you're
in a remote place in a national park for
example um we explored using water
pressure instead of air pressure for
this okay so computers based on air they
have their place but uh I also really
like traditional Electronics I think
they're super interesting or I I I
really like basic Electronics I'm going
to say that so the thing about
Electronics the way that they're
normally used in these devices is still
really irritating right like even when
we say we want to include Electronics
this idea of assembling all of them and
powering all of them and using
microcontrollers to sample them is still
like not the best so there's been a lot
of work in HCI um especially in digital
fabrication to make devices that instead
modify signals used by other devices so
what that usually looks like is uh these
things have specially printed conductors
inside of them these are all 3D printed
they have specially printed conductors
inside um that redirect in some way the
the conductive or excuse me the
capacitive signal of the user onto the
capacitive touch screen so in this case
we have passive plastic stuff that
redirects our signals to another active
device which is a much more convenient
way than putting Active Electronics in
every device hopefully that makes sense
um but the challenge with these devices
is that when you set them on the screen
of course you have to sense them so uh
there's basically two ways is to sense
multiple inputs on something like a
touch screen one is space multiplexing
so this device if I touch it in the top
left corner that has some specific spot
on the touch screen where the signal
comes out and if I touch it on the top
right corner that has some specific
different place on the screen where it
comes out so as I add more inputs I also
have to add more footprint right so it
comes out in different places on the
touch screen and I can tell those inputs
apart the other way that you can do it
well okay this is an obvious limitation
right so bigger many more inputs
requires many more or much more space on
our device the other way we can do it is
time multiplexing so this is i squ c
communication I don't know if you've
ever worked with this before but
basically when we have wires if we send
signals over time ones and zeros over
time we can encode any data we want
that's like sort of the whole idea of
the internet and everything else um we
can send arbitrary amounts of data if we
have arbitrary amounts of
time this is also somewhat Limited
because it requires additional time to
sense or understand additional inputs
and I've also never seen a passive
version of this so this is always this
always requires Active Electronics um
with power sensing and responding to
stuff so I'm going to introduce a
different idea which is called signal
space multiplexing and I hope you will
indulge my journey into uh electrical
engineering for just one second um the
idea of signal space multiplexing is
that we're going to create different
signals that are neither space
multiplexed nor time multiplexed but
that are all sent at the same time and
can be
differentiated we'll see how we do okay
the way your phone works you basically
touch and you connect there's there's a
bunch of transmitting wires going one
way and there's a bunch of receiving
wires going the other way and when you
touch them your finger takes out a tiny
amount of current usually we talk about
these as capacitive interfaces because
our bodies have a capacitive syst
signature so there's some coupling
between your body and the screen that
causes this current to come
out however it turns out based on this
paper by ikumatsu andio that it's not
just capacitance that they measure it's
this other quantity called impedance so
impedance connects capacitance
resistance and another quantity called
inductance which I'm basically going to
ignore for this
talk but but instead of using only
capacitive input on these things on our
phones we can actually use resistive
input on them too which is kind of
cool but because impedance actually
measures capacitance and resistance we
can think about those things as separate
quantities instead of just thinking
about the the single impedance
essentially length Vector number that uh
we're getting from the touch device we
can break it down into its individual
elements so impedance is a complex
resistance of a circuit so it has a real
component and it has an imaginary
component the real component is what we
call resistance and the imaginary
component is what we call capacitance
but touch devices report Instead This
value
okay it turns out there is a device that
instead of just reporting impedance can
actually report the real and complex or
the real and imaginary components
separately so that's an LCR meter and
it's something that electrical engineers
use all the time you can ask it so l is
uh inductance and then C which we're
going to see next is capacitance and
then R is resistance and these are all
passive parts of impedance this quantity
that our phones tell
us so one of my new PhD students who is
an electrical engineer got totally
excited about this and was like how can
we use these individual Parts separately
in the same circuit so let's talk about
that here we have a button which is
based on Resistance so we've hooked it
up to our LCR meter we have a simple
circuit where it goes through the button
back to the LCR meter as you can see on
the screen the number changes when we
press the button okay so the resistance
is changing so okay we pressed the
button or we didn't press the
button we could do the same thing with
the capacitive button we hook up the
capacitive button in a simple circuit
when we see the capacitance change we're
like okay we press the button not that
exciting however when we put the two
buttons in the same simple circuit we
can actually tell which one changed
because we can look at the resistance
and the capacitance separately even
though they're in one circuit and
they're passive
devices because they change their
signatures differently we can tell okay
I know that the resistance is changing
of this circuit so I know I pressed the
resistive button or I know the capacitor
is changing so I know I pressed the
capacitive
button we can also figure out how much
resistance we added so there's this
simple way that resistance is related
the total resistance of a circuit is
just the resistance the sum of all the
resistances in it the total capacitance
of the circuit is related in this uh
sort of annoyingly um inverted way but
based on the total capacitance that we
read of a circuit we can tell how much
capacitance we have added since the last
time we checked so this means we can
stack multiple stuff so all of these
Circle discs that he's adding are
resistors and the square diss are
capacitors and you can see that we can
count up how many we've added because we
know what the total resistance is we
know what the resistances of our circles
are so we can tell how many we've put in
the
thing we can also do continuous
measurement so here we have a joystick
which works in 2D we have a capacitance
going this way and we have resistance
going this way and when we see the
continuous changes we can map it to a 2d
continuous change even though we still
only have one
wire
uh the other thing
is all continuous inputs look the same
so we had to do a small trick to get
multiple variable things per L yeah so
if we want to have multiple sliders that
are resistive it's a little bit hard to
tell which one we slid right because one
ohm change looks the same no matter
where it comes from but we can actually
do this trick where instead of having it
be continuous we have steps so here we
have a big plate smaller plate smaller
plate and we can tell what the
difference is going to be when we slide
to these different plates so instead of
seeing a smooth change we see a stepped
change so in this way we can have
multiple variable components these two
are resistive these two are capacitive
and because we know what the relative
sizes of the steps are we now know which
ones we're
changing so anyway there's a lot of
physical laws and also material laws
that govern how these things work which
I'm not going to talk about
but the thing that I think is really
cool is that we can 3D print all of them
so we're always back to 3D printing um
we did a bunch of experiments to explore
how to do that of course we built
another uh design tool that helps people
create capacitors and resistors of their
desired uh
values um we also managed to manufacture
them well okay we confirmed that uh even
though 3D printers do this Shady thing
where they sort of Stack stuff up and
they're really uh they're not creating
homogeneous materials they still behave
in the way that we would expect them to
behave they're roughly uh proportional
to to what we would expect them to be
proportional to when we change the
lengths and and uh dimensions of these
devices and we can manufacture them
these these rates don't look amazing but
compared to what you actually buy in the
store which is usually like plus or
minus 10% on these uh components it's
actually not too bad for for printing
them
out and anyway because we can control
the geometry we can also error correct
so uh if we predict things um if we have
a slider that's got a capacitor on one
side and a resistor on the other side
even if we aren't perfectly getting the
exact values we expect because we can
have multiple channels at the same time
we can still do this error correction so
the capacitive resistor plus the
resistive signature or excuse me the
capactive signature plus the resistive
signature together give us a better
signal than either one by
itself one thing about this is that it's
not quite compatible with our
smartphones yet so we're looking into
how we can do do these on regular quote
unquote um sensing devices as opposed to
this like weird electrical engineers
tool but uh the other cool thing is that
you can actually use these with gloves
on so it doesn't matter if your body's
capacitive or resistive because it's
it's all contained within the devices
although I guess the glove thing maybe
you don't care in Stanford We Care a Lot
More in
Denmark um we also have thought a little
bit about inductance but it's not nearly
as popular in HCI for whatever reason
probably because we have capacitive
touch
screens so anyway we we had a lot of fun
exploring uh signal space multiplexing
and the kinds of things that we can do
by splitting up this supposedly simple
signal into multiple parts and looking
at all the parts
separately okay now we're just going to
talk about shapes which is hopefully way
easier than electrical engineering um
the question is how should devices be
shaped uh we can design focused on users
so we uh we were thinking about I found
this industrial design thesis that says
that there are no detailed guidelines
for Designing Everyday Life Products
adapted to the users anthropometrics and
physics which is sort of a horrifying
statement when you think about it like
the idea that we have people who
professionally do this kind of design
and are telling us that there aren't
guidelines to do it is um I I found it
moderately sketchy but uh but there are
some kinds of guidelines so ergonomic
guidelines have been around for a long
long time they say simple things like we
want the largest possible contact area
between a surface and our hand so when
I'm designing like a drill handle you
know I want to be able to touch as much
of it as possible I don't want a tiny
drill handle that I'm like pinching in a
weird way right um we also need to be
able to wrap our fingers around them in
a particular way we want to align it to
our wrists so that we're not giving
ourselves carpal tunnel etc etc
um the thing about Mass manufacturing is
that everybody gets the same same
devices right but with digital
fabrication of course we can help users
get their own devices so my other PhD
student who's a mechanical engineer um
he's thinking a lot about how we can
help people create these devices suited
to themselves um also as a heads up this
is still very much work in progress so
I'm excited to hear your comments and
thoughts about
it so okay parametric geometry is
something that basically says we can
take a shape and we can Define it
relative to some
measurement um for example I 3D printed
my husband's wedding ring and basically
what I did to do that is I measured how
big his finger was and then I said I
want the circle of the Ring to be as big
as his finger right that's parametric
geometry it just rescales stuff to fit
other stuff so in this case it makes
sense that all we have to do is make
parametric geometry that integrates hand
dimensions and that follows the rules
right I just showed you the rules
there's rules so the problem's done
right I mean no it turns out that it's
not so sometimes the rules actually turn
out to conflict um sometimes if we have
an existing object like a drill or a
game controller where the grip is bigger
than our hands are already the ideal
grip for us is smaller than it started
out with which means we can't just print
and add more stuff um it's also the case
that if you're designing something from
scratch and you want a whole bunch of
buttons on it it can be really
complicated to fit them all so at the
end of the day the user has to be
involved with these kinds of decisions
so uh okay I'm going to talk about those
in a second um so at the end of the day
users have to be involved wow that's
super low resolution I apologize um so
another Fusion 360 plugin super cool um
we we built this software system that
lets users think about how they want to
integrate the rules and the dimensions
and all of this stuff so we uh we start
by scanning people's hands and getting
their preferences for for what the the
rotation of their wrist should be in its
sort of rest
position um um and then we can go
through the flow of the tool so here
we're designing this Precision Tool that
has a trigger so this is um this is a
device that you would use to uh
precisely sort of Select or cut things
it's actually a medical tool so it's for
for surgeries so we're trying to like
direct people's hands in a very precise
way so in this case we specify kind of
the whether we want a Precision grip or
a power grip and then you know if we
want input input components so in this
case we have this this button trigger
thing it'll basically place them um from
scratch for the
user um we can also lay out a whole
bunch of buttons we have not tried
generating a twiddler yet although that
is going to be one of our stress tests
which I'm very excited about have any of
you ever seen a twiddler before by the
way other than Michael have you seen a
twiddler before it's the one-handed
keyboard yeah yeah it's a it's a
keyboard that you you enter Letters by
pressing multiple keys at the same time
so instead of pressing the a key to
press a you press like you know your
middle finger and your first finger to
press a and then anyway it's very
uh they were popular in the 9s but
anyway they have a ton of
buttons were Max popularity there we go
yeah Peak popularity in the '90s perfect
um but it's a great stress test to see
you know how many buttons can we fit on
an
object uh we can also add geometry to
existing tools so if we take the
existing tool model uh here we've got
the existing tool in Gray and then we've
got our custom geometry in yellow um we
can print some stuff out and we can glue
it on to our existing tool so sometimes
as I mentioned uh it can be the case
that our perfect grip is actually
smaller than the existing grip so we
also have to help users add stuff on um
so that they can align the forces of
their new grip with the uh the actual
power axis of their
device um we had a whole bunch of users
come into our lab and test out
customized devices versus default
devices to do a bunch of different tasks
so we made the them saw things drill
things type on those horrific keyboards
that I showed you made them play
Nintendo we made them dig in the dirt um
and except for the twiddler task
actually these studies were very popular
people loved doing these uh tasks but we
measured we we videotaped their
performance um and we measured uh some
features of the grips so we measured how
well do they actually adhere to these
guidelines it turns out by following the
rules we adhere to the rules incredible
um
and uh but this is this is only sort of
like alignment features and one of the
most interesting features I think is
contact area so max contact area is
super super important um and the way
that we figured out how much contact
area we had with a tool was actually we
froze the tools and then handed them to
people and then we took thermal pictures
of their hands yeah that was super fun
people did not like it but uh but anyway
we got these really nice pictures and we
do some basic computer vision to figure
out you know what's the area difference
between the the default and the
personalized
tool um based on contact area our tools
all did better uh they also increased
user performance in a lot of cases
except for in the Nintendo case because
it turns out we had one relatively older
user who had played a ton of Nintendo on
the original controllers and he kind of
threw off all our statistics but that's
fine um we asked him about our excuse me
we asked them about their experiences
and this is one of the questions that we
asked so there was a lot of variation
between user preferences and we found
some interesting stuff like it turns out
that the shape of our hands is not
everything so people had different
hardnesses of hand which affected how
well the grips worked in their hands um
and that's never been captured in
ergonomic guidelines so we're interested
to see like where that
goes so in addition to different things
for every user we're also interested in
different inputs for every task this is
something we haven't done yet but uh
these are as I'm sure you can see
keyboard heat maps and they are for
three different video games can anyone
guess any of these video games based on
the heat
maps and also tell me why you think it's
that user lick my nasol it seems like
maybe they're playing a platformer
because the like WD keys are very hot
which are usually like navigating keys
mhm yeah is Razer maybe like Starcraft
or something like that cuz they're not
using the right side of the keyboard I
imagine it's just left-handed Mouse the
whole time MH
mm other
thoughts
so Starcraft not not a platformer
exactly but the WD thing was bang on so
this is you know csgo uh World of
Warcraft is interesting because you get
the WD heat but then you also get um
chat so uh so it's sort of like a
general use of the whole keyboard um but
anyway the point is that the difference
in these tasks on the same input device
is totally measurable so we can tell
apart different tasks by looking at
their fingerprints but we can also
measure specific people as they perform
those tasks so uh it could reveal things
about like personal style right if I'm
looking at um people playing balers gate
then uh if I look at my keyboard heat
map as it develops then we can figure
out whether I'm the kind of person who
needs fast access to the fireball button
or whether I'm the person who needs fast
access to the Run button right so this
is sort of a a question of what do we
need to give you like specific users
access to as they're doing their own
specific tasks so this is future work
for this uh layout question of of where
do we put things on
devices
okay now we've talked a lot about
intentional design um for these deeply
customed devices we talked about sensing
and we talked about shape uh but what if
we don't have the time or ability to
design exactly the right thing at
exactly the right time for what we
need one thing we can do is just pick up
whatever is around right so if you've
heard the term ubiquitous Computing the
dream of ubiquitous Computing is that
Computing vanishes into our environments
and everything you know could be
computational maybe it's computational
maybe it's not uh but there's a lot of
interesting interactive objects already
in our environments so for example this
pair of scissors right this is
interactive we go like this that's an
interaction we also have this rubber
band also interactive we've got water
bottles we know how to screw and unscrew
water bottles um and there's tons of
these like physical affordances on
passive devices that are already
everywhere around
us this could uh if we think about this
in a computational context then we could
do something like slide a slider when we
you know move a a box knife in and out
or or we could zoom a picture by
stretching a rubber band or we could
squeeze this ball to uh control um a
volume thing or we could twist a dial to
twist a dial right um I actually think
this is hilarious because the idea that
we took a physical dial and then turn it
into a Digital widget which we now are
controlling back again with a physical
widget sort of appealing on like an art
level but anyway that's what we're going
to talk about
doing so how could we possibly sense
interacting with a water bottle
we have to look instead of looking at
instrumenting the water bottle instead
of instrumenting the human so we've got
all this cool stuff in our arm um these
images are from Gray's
Anatomy book not TV and uh they show all
the weird things that we have inside so
the dark gray stuff is muscles the uh
bright yellow stuff is um uh tendons the
red stuff is arteries um oh no I'm sorry
the the yellow stuff is nerves the red
stuff is arteries and the orange stuff
is tendons so we have all these
different things in different parts of
our arm and as we do tasks they're all
sending each other mechanical signals
and electrical signals so um for example
if you think about your heartbeating
right there's a mechanical signal where
this is when people go like this on your
wrist right they're feeling for that
mechanical signal of the blood pushing
through your veins you can also I'm I'm
lucky that my wrist is very obvious when
I do this but when you wiggle your
fingers around you can see the tendons
changing right in your wrist and uh the
position of those is actually uniquely
determined by the position of your
fingers um we can also tell so if you
close your hand and then you squeeze it
harder your fingers haven't moved but
the amount of force that your outputting
has moved so the tension on your muscles
and tendons also changes so we can tell
not just what shape your hand is in but
how much force you're outputting just
based on looking at what's going on in
your
wrist so as I said you know the the pose
and motion of the things in our wrist
can tell us a little bit about you know
if if my hand is in this shape I'm
probably holding something of this shape
right so the shape of my hand is now
telling me something about the shape of
what I'm interacting with um the motion
of my hand is telling me something about
the way in which I'm interacting with it
and then as we also mentioned we can
tell from the muscle tension uh the
force that we're exerting or maybe the
weight of the object that we're
holding this is work that I did while I
was in Industry um with my colleagues
and an intern at taxal Labs uh that we
presented at Tei last
year so we built this really cool
wristband which uh uses capacitive
sensing to look at essentially a high
resolution depth map of your wrist as
you do different stuff with it um so we
can see here the signature changing as
the hand moves around and as it
stretches out this rubber
band we put this on a whole bunch of
different people and I'm sure you will
not be surprised to learn that different
people's wrists look different um
especially you can see this is this okay
so the green thing at the top is our
sensor and then the flesh different
flesh colored things are like the
inferred shape of the wrist so these
were wrists at rest and then we have the
circumference of the forearm of
different people and you can see there's
huge changes from the smallest wrists
that we looked at to the biggest wrists
that we looked at partially due to like
the tightness of our device
but
the point is that we uh we learned that
it's not going to be easy to get enough
data to make one machine learning model
work for everybody right so these risks
were just too different so we focused on
like one user at a time um and we did
some analysis this is a thing from
biology that uh lower is better so 0.1
is kind of low so it tells us that we're
looking at probably the same structure
but it's not low enough that we can
actually like use the data over and over
then we looked at taking it off and
putting it back onto the same person's
wrist so these are repeat um
performances of of the same user over
time and you can see that the shape more
or less stays the same so that's super
good uh and here we have a a smaller
number so 05 is small enough that we can
reuse data between placements to an
extent um we know that a user's wrist
continues to look the same which is very
much a
relief um so okay to understand whether
we could see what force does to people's
arms we were doing this during Co so we
actually sent them a big envelope full
of Springs we sent out 15 big envelopes
of Springs um so there were 10 Springs
in each envelope that had different
forces required to squish them and we
made them squish the Springs so this is
uh squishing a light spring and a
slightly heavier spring and a heavier
spring so you can see that in addition
to the uh muscle tension required
there's also a change in the user's hand
po actually which is interesting when
they squeeze stuff of different forces
um and we got like a reasonable error 13
Newtons when we're on this scale of 4 to
49 is not amazing but it does show us
that there is some correlation here in
the
data we also wanted to understand
whether this pose thing that I said was
correct so can we tell from a user's
hand pose what the shape of the object
is or like are their grips essentially
repeatable so we sent them a bunch of
Play-Doh in different shapes there were
six there were four objects that they
used six different grasps on so you can
see the six grasps here and we got
classification accuracy of
81% this is the stuff that I think is
way less interesting than this part so
even though the data was not as amazing
as we would have liked we still decided
that we would go ahead and build a
system to see if we could do what I
talked about before where you squeeze a
ball to control the volume um so we
built this system where basically you
demonstrate the extremes so here I'm
demonstrating the maximum the middle
position and and then the minimum and
then we send this to our uh machine
learning pipeline we do feature
extraction and we train two models so
one to tell us what kind of interaction
we're doing and one to tell us where in
the range we
are so when I go activate the uh thing
it's first comparing my twisting to all
of these other things I have planned to
figure out okay okay so she's twisting
perfect and then it's regressing where
in the twist I
am so this do actually enable this is
like real um data this enables these
sort of magical interactions with
passive stuff in our environments just
by sensing what our hands are
doing um and we had users do a study
where they had to input values using
their chosen devices this one I loved
because it's actually an oscilloscope
that he turned off which would normally
sense you know the dial twisting but
instead he sensed it from his wrist
anyway it's just a fun fun thing that he
did um so so we can use these for for
useful input and our users told us that
they felt like superheroes uh they had
all these very positive things to say
about using the objects and it turns out
that the quantitative data we collected
said that they didn't do any better with
the objects than they did by just doing
freehand gestures but they liked them
better so that's what's important I
guess one thing that I like here as an
idea is that uh instead of having um
devices we intentionally 3D print that
are full of sensors we could actually
make stuff out of cardboard right so we
can prototype we could do paper
prototyping and then sense people's
interactions with it and I haven't done
this followon study yet but I think it's
very exciting to think about what's the
lowest lowest barrier to entry way that
we could do prototyping of physical
stuff all right the last thing I'm going
to talk about is a slightly crazy way to
combine uh the ideas of design and
sensing um which I'm currently like in
the early planning stages of so this is
like a Grant application that I've
submitted and we're going to see if
anybody thinks that it's believable so
uh this is what it is like today when
you need an object with which to
interact with your
environment here you have found a screw
which you need to drive into some wood
um and you don't have a screwdriver but
you know that's easy enough so we can if
we have the skills we can 3D model a
screwdriver or we can go to thingiverse
and download a screwdriver or whatever
so we uh find this 3D model and then we
print it out and then we go and we're
like oh this is actually not the right
screwdriver right so we actually needed
a Phillips head screwdriver the Plus
instead of the Flathead so okay we can
go back and iterate but this is like a
little bit
annoying um in the case of Philips head
versus Flathead you don't have to be a
screwdriver expert to figure out that
you need the shape of the screwdriver to
fit the shape of the screw um but there
are other challenges that can be way
more complicated so for example if a
screw is in a corner you might need a
special device that transforms your
twisting of the screw so that it goes
into the corner the right way if the
screw is stripped maybe a Philips head
or a flathead will not work you need
actually something special which will
help you fit into that bit um and then
if you can't output the amount of torque
that's required to move the screw then
you might need a special device that
lets you use larger muscle groups to to
actually get it out of there
right so this comes back to uh the
challenges um by this industrial
designer so there's no detailed
guidelines for how to help people design
these
things so instead of Designing
them the the way that you actually do
this design is really con complex to
conceptualize even for people who do
physical design stuff um you require
knowledge about the task you require
knowledge about the tool you require
knowledge about the user and you may not
have all of those things when you go to
design the tool right there's Dynamic
interactions between them that are
challenging to predict even in this
world world of like Mega big Ai and uh
it's it's also the case of course that
you need to know then how to 3D model
and how to 3D print and all this
stuff so the idea that I have is instead
of doing modeling explicitly through a
user or a designer requesting stuff
before we make these objects we instead
have the user demonstrate and fail to do
things while they're doing the task so
in the screwdriver scenario we can start
with the basic screwdriver and then
using knowledge of our surroundings we
can design we can optimize the design to
make sure the screw is reachable we can
print it with embedded sensing
structures so that it can tell how well
it's contract contacting the screw head
uh as well as you know the amount of
torque that we're outputting onto it and
then from the sensed output that we're
getting from this screwdriver we can
iteratively print new screwdrivers that
are getting better and better right so
we can evolve the screwdriver to the
task that we're doing with the
screw so to go through sort of the whole
thing um you find a screw that you're
aiming to fasten and you give some
command whatever get a basic screwdriver
uh and then because of what we know
about your body um and the space that
you're working in we give you a
screwdriver that's got a right angle
already on it um that's balanced well
for your
muscles um we can also decide that maybe
the most important thing to print
instead of you know printing the whole
screwdriver each time maybe all we need
to print is the bit so 3D printers are
unfortunately very stupid and they start
at the bottom of an object and they
print up but instead we can try to think
about
what is a Salient part what's the
important part of the screwdriver to
print and maybe we print that first so
we don't start at the bottom and go up
we instead start at the important part
which is the bit test it out
first but of course we don't want an
ordinary bit we want something that's
got sensing inside so then when we go
and print the things and test them out
we can tell how well we're contacting
the screw how well we're outputting the
force that we expected and then we can
iterate based on what we see just
reprinting parts that aren't performing
well so we end up with a screwdriver
that evolves as we use it to perfectly
match the task the context and
us so I think that this idea of taking
modeling out of the equation and instead
authoring through failure is uh pretty
interesting um so if we Define authoring
as guessing and using and sensing and
iterating then uh we get rid of this
whole idea that we know what the problem
is upfront because we often don't know
what the problem is up front um and
thinking about how
how to interact then with systems that
are sort of like understanding our
failure in situ is sort of exciting and
I did use I wrote F fix verify in here
by the way just
uh iote I don't know
um but uh the other thing about this is
that even though I use 3D printing all
the time to make finished objects I
don't think that it should be a tool
that we use at the end of a chain to
make an object that we know is going to
be the right object right I think it's
an opportunity for us to interact with
something physical that we might use in
different ways um they're not just
static configurations of like a big
chunk of material they're things that we
can more or redefine or
reconfigure um we can also use this
opportunity to think about like critical
paths and stuff and I know that this is
something that's done in manufacturing
where you don't want to like prototype
the whole thing each time but I think in
HCI we've lost a little bit of that in
our digital fabrication research
I also have a lot of colleagues that
work on VR and uh they find it
compelling that the virtual world can be
changed rapidly using only software um
but I think that if we put sensing in
the right places and use it in the right
ways we can actually change the physical
world just the same as we do in Virtual
Reality so VR in this case um uses the
fact that we've tied sensing and
rendering together into a single system
but now that fabrication is sort of this
more sophisticated uh um technology uh
and we can leverage you know the speed
and and flexibility of it I think that
we can do the same the same kind of
thing with with fabrication um so this
this project that I have here basically
what they did was they had users
pressing different buttons right and
then over time they made the user
fingers longer and longer so that they
got better performance on the buttons
and I think we can do the same thing
with fabrication I think we could do the
same thing in the real world
so okay so we made it through a lot of
different projects that get around the
idea of finding or making input devices
that are well matched to users or their
tasks or their contexts we talked about
shape talked about sensing we also
talked about completely ignoring shape
and sensing and focusing on usage um and
letting devices emerge sort of from the
context in which they're being used and
then uh yeah as I noted these are in
varying stages of completion all these
projects I mentioned so I'm really
excited to hear your questions um of
course I want to thank my collaborators
at KU and everywhere else and this is
not all of them this slide um anyway I
need a bigger slide that's all I
need uh I also want to thank the people
who give me money to do these things
because I love money um and now I'm
happy to take your
[Applause]
questions yeah I really love the last
research vision of like iterating
through failure and also designing like
specific things and not like end to
endend things in fabrication I was
wondering if you thought a little bit
about the sustainability like um
implications for that because I would
imagine like with iteration and also
physical fabrication comes a bunch of
like build prints and like stuff for
sure um yeah so part of the the thing
that I think about that is many of the
projects that I work on are actually
focused on how can we make structural
interactive devices as opposed to
electronic based ones so they are for
example air logic is already more
sustainable than something else even
though it's not as fancy as something
electronic based you can just throw the
whole thing in the recycler and yes I
agree that there is a sustainability
perspective um but I think that it can
be mitigated through using the right
kinds of design and essentially like
improved Material Science it's totally
like an active area of research right
now M so uh so when we start out does it
is it supposed to just look like the way
like a regular screwdriver or something
looks and then or like I guess what I'm
thinking about was was the very first
iteration and then like what we did it
through to like yeah so so I imagine
starting with something basic or or
something that we
can there's certain things like I talked
about the hands right so I can already
know how big your hands are there
there's no mystery there right um but
the question about like the dynamic
interaction between you and the stuff
that you're working on that's something
that's really hard to know up front so
we can make some adjustments beforehand
but some have to be made as we do the
task could you comment a little bit more
about like how far you guys have pushed
the the when it comes to air logic like
Beyond just like simple gates to try to
find uh uh I guess facilitate the
interaction like how far have you pushed
it in terms of logic how complex can you
make things um so we can
do right now the way that our system is
built you have to have balanced logic
gates so we can have you know if we do
one and and one and then we can do
another and down here but we can't do an
and and then have an and that's got like
an imbalance because of the way that
we're currently using our uh our air um
in in the historical systems I don't
think I have this slide but uh in the
historical systems they have a slightly
different design that doesn't require
balanced air flow and so that design is
a lot harder to 3D print but you can
actually laser cut it so we're working
on how to laser cut these structures and
then basically like slot them into 3D
prints instead of printing the whole
thing because there there is still a ton
more that we can do it just requires not
having the like crappy ridges right the
crappy ridges mess everything
up yeah in the space of like not your
problem I'm
curious for the for example for the top
two projects there m you kind of
gesticulated toward well we can't do
this yet in everyday touch screens is
that because the touch screen is it's
just a matter of the math they they're
not doing the math or does is there
something about that sensor you're using
that you actually that is not built in
and likewise with the Tei project I'm
just curious what would it take to embed
that kind of thing into an Apple watch
or something like this like are these
are these far off are these near term
like how hard is this ultimately going
to be so um
the first one about the touch screens
there's there's some extra components
that would need to be added just like
basically capacitors and resistors to
compare to so that you can get these um
values
correctly so there's a little bit of
math and a little bit of extra
electronics uh but I don't think it's
like a far off goal especially
because we don't have to have a general
purpose LCR meter we can like design an
LCR meter that's matched to the stuff we
want to sense right so we can uh be a
little bit smart what we select there um
that's something we are still thinking
about trying to figure out how to do um
in terms of embedding that in an Apple
Watch it's actually bra I don't know
what it would be yeah uh it's actually
almost possible now um the the kind of
sensing that it does is not like
essentially we have this like ugly
prototype thing right which is sort of
bulky but the the sensing technique
itself doesn't require anything special
so it would would uh it would require a
little more of the battery of the watch
and you'd have to be clever about when
you like activate it or whatever but uh
but it I I think that that is actually
maybe more near term than the cell
phones thing because the Apple watch
people are willing to pay a little bit
more than they are on their phones I saw
a hand over here oh yeah I was so for
the computer vision one of using the
objects in context you mentioned you had
two models the first of which to
classify like what motion you're trying
to do and then the second of which to
classify where in the motion I guess I
was curious about that second model cuz
it seems like to classify where you are
in a Twist is different than where you
are in a squeeze like is that second
model really able
to be able to do or is it just like so
it's per it's per interaction so because
we demonstrate the max the middle and
the Min of each thing once we've decided
okay I'm twisting then we look at the
regression just of twisting we can't
generalize that
unfortunately like Anatomy is way too
crazy to generalize stuff which is
that's just life um good question though
uh yeah I had a comment because recently
I seen that Apple has patented the pinch
mechanism using the the watch right so I
think I I don't know how how far from
that we are but I think maybe they're
bringing a point of view of visually uh
judging what you're interacting to and
then Capt infering and and making the
connection even if we if you do it simp
in a simplified way perhaps so I think
it maybe goes towards the your direction
right sure yeah yeah no it's way of
approach I feel like the the pinching
thing has gotten really popular with
arvr stuff and uh and it's
not well I have seen patents that like
listen for the sound of pinching and
patents that like you know do all these
different things like there's been a ton
of different people trying to figure out
how can we tell when people pinch so we
can have them do this in AR and VR but
uh the the thing about this um device
that we worked on is that it works even
if I'm like doing something behind my
back right so I don't have to have the
the glasses but but yeah
there's there's a lot of richness that I
think Apple hasn't quite put in there
yet but I think they they they were
using the capacitance oh were they from
the Apple watch yeah so you close a look
and and by sensing the differences of
inter I don't know if each finger has a
different capacitance but anyways
they're using the actual Apple watch and
together maybe with the vision they
complement oh I see yeah cool I see I'm
going have to look and I I got get
wondering how cool it would be for
learning an instrument for instance
you're sure yeah so you have a Clos not
only sensing the person but
also giving back or maybe you can pinch
less than the string or more right
interest yeah there's yeah there's tons
of cool applications in like manual
skill learning which is again one of
these things where like I have a
colleague working on skill learning in
VR um and uh and I think it's well I
just think it's fun to use her research
everywhere that I can so uh skill
learning in the real world that's what
I'm about
[Laughter]
now all right let's thank our
[Applause]
speaker